we already did with a Megan Lee Megan
first of all congratulations welcome
back to the studio there was a setback
against Anna zatonski but then you
picked yourself back up in our crucial
Victory against uh the co-leader going
into this round Jenny for you how did
you approach this uh game and are you
aware of Jennifer have you played I've
never played Jennifer before the first
time
so I prepared the scotch against her
which I've never played before
um which I had some help with from a
good friend for some of the prep and she
played um were you getting inspired by
your game against Nazi pakiza
Scotch is a pretty safe opening to play
as white you have a pretty
straightforward plan in the variation
that I played
and then you can easily develop your
pieces and I thought maybe if I Castle
queenside I could get like a and did you
expect this move Bishop to C5 uh yeah
she's played it before so
um cool night to B3 Bishop to uh B6 and
by the way you decided against Knight
takes C6 which is one of the main lines
how did you make that decision uh
actually my friend helped me a really
good friend of mine helped me prep this
line so this night to be three months
yeah so I think I was in book until she
played like Knight E5
Knight to E5 all the way
so you anticipated her to block you with
the move A5 like that and now Knight to
E5 this was the moment
got it and what were the plans that you
surely were aware of
um in this position uh I think I have um
either making like a king side break
with my majority or
um I had like this bishop E3 idea
planned which I played uh to trade off
like the dark squared Bishops and I
think it's like a little more
uncomfortable for black with her Knights
to know what to do the nights are a
little bit uncomfortable only five and
E7 and she played this move F5 F4 Knight
G4 this was a critical moment after
Knight to C3 Knight to F6 Rook 21 inch
played this move Bishop to G6 did you
see this move G4 I saw it after I played
directory one
um but I think
because you are definitely aiming at
that move G4 right yeah no I missed that
one but you are still in pole position
to have a nice Advantage how are you
feeling at this point she had only 19
minutes on the clock 50 minutes for you
you built up a very nice advantage on on
the clock and still plenty of moves to
go how are you feeling about your
channel I was feeling pretty confident I
think being able to keep a lot of the
pieces on the board made her spend a lot
of time calculating
um and again I think she's a little
unfamiliar I guess with this variation
as was I so
um I think I was able to build an
advantage on the clock yeah but it also
felt like your moves were much easier
you were just like pushing the pawns
making her life uncomfortable uh Bishop
to F7 G3 Knight to D5 and now Knight to
B5
and now finally you got to this position
what was the next critical moment in
your opinion
um
when she had her quinone D6 and she
started pushing her C pawn and d-pawn
um her structure kind of got a little
looser so I was able to break three or
break through yeah
absolutely and
you ended up into this end game which
you nicely converted after that Megan
congratulations uh you're in the
co-leadership position and right now
with only six rounds to go are you
dreaming about the Championships are you
starting to dream I'm still trying to
focus one game at a time yeah I think
there's still a lot of the tournament
left so anything can happen and who are
you playing tomorrow I think I'm playing
ashrida ashrida okay big matchup against
ashrida who is also actually uh surging
right now through the rankings three
games in a row do you have any
experience with ashrita have you played
before I think we've only played once
last year so and she was I think quite
that game so I'll be white this time
it's going to be a big match we'll let
you go get your rest and your
preparation thank you our
congratulations as well may